So I think what's really fascinating is
that there have been a number of recent
studies looking at brain structural
differences between liberals and
conservatives and what's been found in
several studies is that liberals tend to
have a larger anterior cingulate gyrus.
That is an area that is responsible for
taking in new information and that
impact of the new information on
decision making or choices.
Conservatives tended on the whole to
have a larger right Amygdala,
the Amygdala being a deeper brain
structure.
That process is more info,
um,
emotional information,
specifically fear based information.
So the,
it's really responsible for the flight
or fright response.
And this isn't everybody.
It's not black and white.
And of course then you know,
what about all of the people in the
middle.
But basically the study showed that if
you just based it on brain structural
size difference,
you could predict who would be a
conservative and who would be a liberal
with a frequency of 71 point six
percent,
71 point six percent is a pretty high
ability to predict who is a conservative
and who was a liberal.
Just from brain structure.
When you look at what your parents were
in terms of predicting what you might be
in terms of conservative versus liberal,
that enabled you to predict in studies
at a rate of 69 point five percent,
so very close,
not quite as good.
And why is that interesting?
It's because the brain is plastic.
So the question as to whether you have a
brain structure to start with that
informs whether you will be a liberal or
conservative or whether the formation of
certain thoughts from your parents,
for example,
shapes your brain structure because the
brain is plastic and ever changing,
particularly in youth.
So does thinking certain thoughts or
predominantly let's say utilizing your
right Amygdala versus your anterior
cingulate gyrus inform,
uh,
the growth of those areas and therefore
help you predict later who is liberal
and who is conservative.
So in terms of interpreting the meaning
of a different sides,
structures for a liberal versus a
conservative,
I think you have to look at what that
area is predominantly responsible for.
So for instance,
for conservatives,
if you're right,
Amygdala is in large and that's the fear
processing area.
You would expect,
um,
maybe choices or decisions or character
and personality to be more informed by a
response to a fearful situation.
So for example,
conservatives,
in fact in personality studies do tend
to rate higher in areas of stability.
Loyalty,
I'm not liking change being more
religiously,
um,
uh,
involved in terms of decision making,
having that,
that rate higher for them in making
certain choices.
And if you look at liberals from a
personality character standpoint,
you're going to find stronger ratings in
terms of liking change.
I'm wanting to actually base decision
making on new information,
on science information.
And so those differences are not
surprising in light of these brain
structural differences.
Being a liberal or being a conservative
really is not a black and white.
It's really a bell shaped curve where
you know,
someone who considers themselves
conservative,
maybe far less conservative,
so to speak,
than someone else who still calls
themselves a conservative.
And that bell shaped curve continues all
the way through where in the middle of
there may be a large group that calls
themselves independence.
What we don't know is whether that has
to do with differences in brain
structure.
Um,
and so would we see in independence.
No one's done that study to say,
Oh,
independence,
don't show any differences in brain
structure,
um,
or any differences and say,
risk taking reaction.
So we don't,
we don't know for sure what that means,
but I think it's fair to say that even
when we looked at differences in brain
structure with the reliability of 71
point six percent,
that still leaves a very large number
that don't fit into that category.
So,
you know,
where do they fall out?
Are they more likely to be independence
in their mind?
We don't know the answer to that.
But certainly,
you know,
these are not hard and fast rules.
This is not diagnostic science.
And um,
and people who are independent obviously
have certain characteristics I'll say,
of both sides are somewhere just like
they sound in the middle.
I think by understanding what's going on
structurally in the brain and
functionally in the brain,
we can better understand what informs
people's very strong opinions,
um,
that ultimately inform her political
system,
right?
Because it's one person,
one vote,
and in trying to change people's minds,
I think everybody has to look at what's
behind the ability to change your mind,
you know,
is it really changeable when,
when we look at,
um,
voting and,
and changing minds and say,
political advertising,
you have to recognize that all of that
new information always comes in through
the prism of your brain,
which means that what I say to you
versus you have maybe heard differently
even though I've said the same thing,
so it comes in through the prism of,
does what you said make me nervous and
afraid and therefore I'm going to resort
to my old standby.
I don't want to change my decision or am
I going to hear the same information and
say,
oh,
that's novel.
I have a receptivity to novel
information.
Therefore,
that's interesting to me and I'm going
to think about whether I might change my
mind based on that.
New Information,
I think that's what the science is
basically saying to us that there are
going to be some people who are going to
hear the information and retreat to
their original thinking and other people
who are going to hear new information
and say that really does change my mind
if we're trying to have a society that
will work in its own best interests.
Let's say that we do want to be able to
communicate with one another.
And so if you're a liberal and say you
want to talk to a conservative about gay
marriage,
you want to have in your mind and how it
might still speak to loyalty,
stability and religious belief in some
way that you want to have those ideas in
form your communication as opposed to
simply saying,
but you know,
this percentage of the population is
homosexual and therefore,
you know,
we should consider whether everybody
should have those same rights.
And you know,
science shows,
it's not a choice.
It's,
it's simply a fact your gay or not gay.
Um,
and therefore,
shouldn't those people have the same
rights?
That's not the best way to appeal.
Perhaps to a conservative on this issue,
you want to appeal to them in terms of
how,
for example,
a marital rules or history might be
maintained and not really altered for
those who are in let's say,
a traditional marriage of how it won't
interrupt the fabric for,
for example,
of their lives,
of the rules that they adhere to.
Those kinds of things would be more
appealing to them.
Whether or not that might be the most
appealing argument to you as a liberal.
The truth is a conservative is more
likely to be able to appeal to a liberal
using novel new information that is
science based and showing certain facts
and allowing for it not necessarily to
be purely religiously based,
um,
that not be the rule system.
So to speak,
by being empathically understanding.
And by that I don't mean sympathetically
understanding.
I mean truly being able to stand in the
other person's shoes and have some
insight into where their brain is
directing them and appealing to that
argument.
So if you are conservative,
you will want to appeal with new
information because liberals are more
novelty seeking potentially.
And um,
and often science-based is a good way to
present new information.
Part of what's difficult,
um,
in terms of what I'm seeing now is that
actually people are tending to double
down on their own style and what appeals
to their own group of thinkers and that
is increasingly preventing the kind of
communication that would be important to
our future so that we can't so to speak
cross the aisle because it would require
trying on for size,
the thought pattern of the other group.
It would be saying,
you know,
Oh,
I see,
and that's hard to do.
I literally say that is difficult to do.
So if you're a,
migdal is screaming at you,
you know,
run for the hills or you know,
double down and fight.
It's hard to say,
well,
let me take a step back,
um,
and not have a fear based reaction,
but instead present the science or
present the new information.
A good example would be that of gun
ownership.
If I speak about gun ownership to a
liberal group,
they automatically have thoughts
probably about,
particularly if they are in an urban
area,
crime
and danger.
Because statistically that is what they
have been privy to,
the information has been given to them
about how many homicides are committed,
who is,
you know,
dying by gun violence,
et Cetera.
If I speak about gun ownership to a
conservative group,
they are more likely in their loyal,
stable way to think about a
sportsmanship,
hunting with family,
particularly again,
if they're in a rural area,
because that is what they grew up with.
That is what has been stable for them.
That is the memory that they have about
guns.
And so you can see how that's coming
from two completely different
directions,
perhaps the same word gun,
and that it is hard to stand in the
shoes for,
for example,
of the,
of the other group.
Um,
so that you can,
you can come to make decisions about it.
So for example,
the CDC has been prevented from doing
any research so that we could have new
science about gun violence as a public
health issue.
Uh,
by actually the conservative political
group has said,
you know,
you can't do research on this area.
We won't call it a public health issue.
And therefore,
um,
you're,
you're prevented from getting dollars
and prevented from having research into
gun violence per se,
and that comes probably from a fear
position that if there is any new
information that sways a opinion,
um,
we will lose our loyal standing to
something that we firmly believe in and,
um,
and harks back to very pleasurable,
comforting memories from earlier life.
So it's very complicated in a certain
kind of way.
Um,
you know,
the liberal group is wanting there to be
this research,
not necessarily to take guns away,
but to say we'd like to see the science
to validate whether or not certain
things about guns or good for us or not
good for us.
The most recent study looking at what is
going on in the brain in terms of
politics predicted with the greatest
value,
being able to identify a conservative
versus a liberal 82 point six percent.
And this was a look at brain activity,
which is different.
You put someone in a functional Mri
which is different than just taking a
picture.
It picks up activity in a certain area
of the brain and found that when you
have them do a risky behavior and look
at their activity in their brain,
conservatives were more likely to light
up in the fright and flight response
area.
The amygdala and liberals were more
likely to light up in areas that have to
do with social awareness.
Again,
you could see how therefore this
difference would inform what comes to
the mind of either a liberal or
conservative while either involved in a
risky behavior or even something that's
happening external to them,
but feels like it might impact them in a
risky way.
And that was actually even more
predictive than looking at structure of
the brain or what your parents were in
terms of liberal versus conservative.